[Music]
slowly but surely the movie business is
getting back on track and in addition to
a number of top class films such as
spider-man and dune which will be out
this year we would like to take a look
at some of the most anticipated movies
of 2022
included our mcu blockbusters and
exciting video game adaption and
hard-hitting action so sit back and
enjoy part 1 of our most anticipated
movies of 2022
20 22 will start off with a sequel to a
horror classic scream 5.
consistent with its name the movie is
supposed to directly follow scream 4
from 2011.
in front of and behind the camera the
direction leans more towards a reboot
which of course has a lot to do with the
passing of wes craven the creator of the
film series
with david arquette we will at least see
one really familiar face again as the 49
year old has embodied dooley riley as
the sheriff of woodsborough in every
single scream film so far
also said to be back rnf campbell is
sidney prescott courtney cox's gail
weathers and roger l jackson as the
voice of ghost face
the directory cast will feature two
directors at once namely tyla gillett
and matt bettinelli alpin among other
projects the two are known for directing
the 2019 thriller ready or not
they themselves say wes craven inspired
and influenced them as fans and they are
very honored to continue the lives work
of the director who sadly passed away in
2015.
in terms of content we don't know all
that much yet considering the ones
returning and a couple of new faces it
probably amounts to a normal sequel to
part 4 though therefore the old gang
might meet again to finally put an end
to the masked man after he terrorizes a
few new victims we are definitely
looking forward to the horror slasher
which is scheduled for release on
january 14th
2022 as our second blockbuster of the
month of january we present morbius the
upcoming film is along with venom and
venom 2 the third movie from the
so-called sony spider-man universe and
revolves around the title anti-hero dr
michael morbius the brilliant biochemist
suffers from a difficult to cure blood
disease which he tries to treat himself
needless to say this goes horribly wrong
and so he contracts a form of vampirism
which in the end is arguably even worse
than the original disease itself
the 49 year old multi-talent jared leto
will be seen in the leading role joining
him in front of the camera will be good
omen star adria jonah as the
protagonist's partner and doctor who
actor matt smith who will be embodying
the marvel character laksha's crown also
starring our churnable actor jared
harris along with tyrese gibson who will
play an fbi agent as well as michael
keaton who will be seen as the villain
adrian toombs further it will be
exciting to see whether and how the film
will tie in with venom 2 which is said
in the same universe sony's morbius will
be released in theories on january 28th
2022
in february there will be the release of
the video game adaption uncharted the
focus is on nathan drake who's a
descendant of the renowned seafarer sir
francis drake on his daring expeditions
which can be experienced in four parts
on the playstation so far he regularly
ends up in the most remote places on a
planet this time he sets off in search
of the legendary city of gold el dorado
according to his research it is supposed
to be somewhere in south america and so
this still young explorer in the film
sets off with a journalist and his
mentor victor sullivan in search of the
treasure of course the three are not
alone during their quest and so they
have to compete against other treasure
hunters mercenaries and pirates
in the role of the young nathan drake we
get to see tom holland while fellow
actor mark wahlberg plays a young sully
especially the latter does not really
raise a lot of excitement in the
community given that wahlberg hardly
resembles his video game role model in
the pictures published so far
which might be mainly due to the lack of
the distinctive mustache however the
beard can still be hoped for after all
we're talking about an origin story here
and on instagram wahlberg can indeed be
seen with a typical facial hair you can
convince yourself of the final result in
theaters from february 11 2022
just over three weeks after uncharted
the next movie will then be the batman
in march
set in the 1990s the noir narrative will
pay special attention to batman's
detective skills and will be a
standalone story with no connection to
the dceu much like joker was in 2019
the dark knight solo adventure will be
directed by matt reeves while hollywood
star robert pattinson will assume the
lead role
the now seventh movie batman was not
well received from the start
for remaining the 35 year old is still
too much associated with the teen saga
twilight and this despite the fact that
in recent years he has clearly
emancipated himself from his previous
parts with serious roles such as
intended or the lighthouse
along with pattinson we will also see
performances by numerous villains
including paul dino as the riddler zoe
kravitz as an earlier version of
catwoman colin pharrell as the penguin
and john terturo as carmine falcone
as you can see batman will be very busy
in the upcoming film he can of course
also hope for active support from two
mates namely commissioner james gordon
and his benevolent butler alfred
pennyworth
whether the dark knight can't stand up
to his adversaries is something we will
be able to find out as of march 4th 2022
march will continue to be exciting
thanks to doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
the sequel to the 2016 blockbuster will
as the name suggests take a closer look
at the concept of multiverses after this
was already opened up at the end of the
loki series
the cast is truly gigantic and can
almost compete with the lineup of an
avengers movie it'll feature benedict
cumberbatch as dr steven strange
benedict wong as a loyal companion wong
rachel adams is dr christine palmer chu
talashi for as the main villain carl
mordo elizabeth olsen as won the maximal
fake a scarlet witch and last but not
least social gomes who makes her mcu
debut as the young superhero america
chavez
further rumors suggest appearances by
tom hiddleston as loki bruce campbell
and probably one of the three spider-man
appearing in norway home meaning either
tom holland toby maguire or andrew
garfield obviously other well-known
stars may also feature in the film as
they might still be kept secret behind
the camera sam raimi is in charge of
directing after the original director
scott derekson backed out and is now
acting as executive producer doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
will be released in news theaters on
march 25th 2022
the month of april brings another two
top class films the first is sonic the
hedgehog 2. the sequel revolves around
the new life of the blue hedgehog who
has now found a new home in green hills
among his friends tom and maddie
the threat of dr robotnik's return seems
distant after sonic banished him to a
mushroom planet
just as maddie and tom are on holiday
the villain makes a comeback but he's
not alone
teamed up with knuckles with whom sonic
is not buddies here yet robotnik embarks
on a quest to find a fabled emerald that
holds the power of either destroying or
building entire
civilizations in order to prevent this
incredibly valuable artifact from
falling to the hands of the antagonist
sonic and his friend tales also set out
to find the emerald
as was announced a short time ago idris
elbow will delve the red echidna it goes
without saying that ben swords will once
again be voicing the blue hedgehog while
james marston and tikka sumter will be
back in front of the camera as tom and
maddie together with jim carrey as dr
robotnik
the release of sonic the hedgehog 2 is
scheduled for april 8 2022
marvel's thor franchise has been
thrilling fans around the globe for over
a decade
the witty god of thunder will return to
the big screen again next year for what
is now his fourth movie
after the pandemic upset the plans to
start filming in 2020 the time was right
to begin shooting thor love and thunder
in australia at the start of this year
the plot centers on the one hand on thor
himself as he loses the ability to lift
mjolnir
however the focus will be more on
another character namely dr jane foster
mighty thor as she is also called is
worthy of lifting thor's hammer and
henceforth becomes the mighty goddess of
thunder
in principle the two have similar powers
but it is said that there will be some
subtle differences as well
in front of the camera we can look
forward to chris hemsworth as thor
natalie portman as jane foster tessa
thompson as valkyrie and christian bale
as gore the god butcher among many other
familiar faces the release date of thor
love and thunder is set for may 6 2022
the action in john week 4 promises to be
very intense
you don't need to be a clairvoyant to
suspect that this time around we'll be
dealing with a rather angry john wick he
and the bowery king are out for revenge
against the high table the continental
and of course his manager winston
featured on screen will be keanu reeves
as john wick lawrence fishburne as the
bowery king
ian mcshane as winston and lance reddick
as the concierge charon one newcomer is
japanese british pop star arena sabayama
who like martial arts legends donnie yen
and scott atkins is expected to take on
an unspecified role likewise joining the
cast in recent weeks and months have
been marco zero hiroyuki zanada chemier
anderson clancy brown and bill skosgod
this is absolutely a cast to be excited
about
john wick chapter 4 will be released on
may 27 2022 in the united states
in june we can look forward to the
conclusion of an extremely successful
film series with the release of jurassic
world dominion the hype is huge although
the date of the release is still several
months in the future one contributing
element is certainly the return of some
of the actors from the 1993 original as
laura dern jeff goldblum and sam neal
will be seen together on the big screen
for the first time in years other
returning actors who will be seen
alongside chris pratt and the like
include bd wong as dr henry wu justice
smith as franklin webb and omar sai as
barry samban director colin trevorrow
further revealed that the 1993 stars
will have about as much screen time as
those in the jurassic world trilogy thus
nostalgic should get their money's worth
not much is known about this story yet
now that macy lockwood has released all
the dinosaurs there are many
possibilities as to which direction
jurassic world dominion could take
is it more in terms of coexistence
between humans and dinosaurs or are the
prehistoric creatures a massive threat
to humanity after all
should this be the case
how will the beasts be dealt with
jurassic world dominion will hit cinemas
on june 10 2022
after jurassic world dominion in june
the action continues with the
transformers rise of the beasts
as the name suggests the seventh
installment in the film series will be
the first live action film to focus on
the beast wars saga
the movie will be set in 1994 seven
years after the events of bumblebee
the setting is new york city brooklyn
respectively where the plot is supposed
to have a lot of connections to the
local hip-hop scene
epic transformers battles will not only
take place there though because part of
the story also plays out in machu picchu
in peru
center of attention is once again fan
favorite optimus prime who is again
being dubbed by peter cullen to the joy
of many fans
in the movie he will not only fight
against the familiar decepticons
together with his autobots since he must
also face the new threat posed by the
terrorcons and the maximals all in all
you can expect an action-packed movie
that will take the same direction as the
michael bay films as producer lorenzo di
buenaventura promises transformers rise
of the beasts will be released in
theaters on june 24 2022
exactly one week later minions the rise
of growth follows the sequel to the
extremely successful predecessor from
2015 was actually supposed to be
released in 2020 but was then postponed
along with many other productions
and in terms of content the film is said
to be an origin story involving the
villain grew
the focus will be on his first time
meeting up with the minions when he
saved them from scarlet
most of the plot will be set in the
1970s where gru then still 12 years old
made his first plans to become the
greatest villain of all time as in the
predecessor the terrific cast around the
dubbing actors will provide the right
atmosphere
the cast includes steve corrales grew
and pure coffin as kevin stewart bob and
rookie otto also featured will be the
vicious six featuring taraji p hanson as
bell bottom michelio as master
and danny trejo as stronghold
allegedly the group's former leader wild
knuckles will also make his return
the director will be called baldo while
the screenplay will be provided by
writer brian lynch
minions the rise of crew will be
released on july 1 2022
another week later is the release of
black panther wakanda forever the latest
mcu adventure not only has to cope with
the painful loss of chadwick boseman but
also tie in with its highly successful
forerunner what is clear is that there
will not be a new king t'challa instead
disney wants to expand the black panther
universe and introduce new characters
one of them is iron heart to whom a
separate series will also be dedicated
later often referred to as ironman's
successor riri williams is a student at
the renowned mit and quite skilled at
crafting new armor and weapons we will
get to see the new villain namor who
along with the other new additions will
let us dive a bit deeper into the
mythological world of wakanda
fortunately many actors from the first
park celebrate their return for instance
leticia ride as shuri lupita nyong'o as
nakia winston duke as baku and angela
bassettes ramonda
especially shuri will be given a
significant spotlight according to
reports another attorney is martin
freeman scia agent everett ross
new to the cast is michael cole in as
yet unknown role as well as the
initially mentioned reary williams who
will be portrayed by dominic thorne once
again ryan coogler will be in charge of
directing the movie while marvel boss
kevin feige will be the producer black
panther wakanda forever will be released
on the big screen on july 8 2022.
the fifth part of the legendary indiana
jones series awaits us in the same month
in spite of initial skepticism on the
part of harrison ford who is now 79
years old and doubts whether the project
would ever be continued the crew finally
decided to bring indiana jones 5 to the
big screen after all
after discussions about the casting of
the main character harrison ford
clarified that there could be no indiana
jones without him which is why the
veteran actor is returning to his
signature role along with him we will
see much mickelson phoebe walla bridge
boyd holbrook toby jones thomas
scratchman and chenette renee wilson on
the screen each in as yet unknown roles
unfortunately nothing is known about the
plot yet we only know that the director
will no longer be steven spielberg but
james mangald the expected release date
for indiana jones 5 is july 29th 2022
on the same day the shazam spin of black
adam will be released
for many the eponymous anti-hero may not
be as well known as other colleagues
from the dc universe but the hype around
him is at least as great
the story of black adam is a spin-off to
shazam from 2019 and is expected to be a
much gloomier film than the latter black
adam's real name is that adam who is the
son of an egyptian pharaoh and an
extremely violent contemporary
the justice society of america and its
four representatives will also be
playing a role
dwayne johnson will take on the role of
the titular anti-hero while pierce
brosnan will be seen as dr fate noah
centineo as atom smasher eldest hodges
hockman
sarah shahi as adriana thomas and
contessa swindell as cyclone
jungle troops director jean-colisera is
responsible for directing and the script
is by adam stikel rory haynes and
saurabh noshervani
dc's black adam will be released in
theaters on july 29 2022
in late september 2022 mission
impossible 7 will then be released tom
cruise who is still a very vigorous 49
year old will once again take on the
role of ethan hunt for the seventh time
the upcoming blockbuster is a direct
sequel to mission impossible fallout and
will be brought to the screen by
director christopher mcquarrie once more
little is known about the content sadly
but we can nevertheless speculate that
things will heat up the reason for this
assumption is not only the franchise
reputation but above all the stunts that
cause quite a sensation during filming
take for example the gigantic ramp from
which tom cruise jumps on the motorcycle
and then opens his parachute at the very
last moment mcquarrie feels the same way
speaking about it in the podcast of the
us magazine empire stating that the
helicopter's done for mission impossible
fallout will look pretty dull in
comparison to the new stuns whether this
is really the case can be seen starting
on september 30th 2022
in october the next movie will be
spider-man into the spider-verse 2.
miles morales second adventure has been
in production since summer 2020 and is
expected to be as popular as its
predecessor
this is probably going to be difficult
to achieve given that the first
multiverse spectacle even won an oscar
for best animated film the content of
the second part will be similar to that
of the previous one since miles has met
several spider-friends from different
universes in addition the focus will be
on the romantic relationship between
miles and quinn which was somewhat
neglected in the prequel according to
producers chris miller and floyd silk
aka cindy moon and spider-punk will also
make their way into the sequel in
addition to the countless spider-man and
spider-woman also generating excitement
is a hint from the teaser video that
suggests that takuya yamashiro aka
spiderman will also be featured in the
movie
there's news about the voice actors as
well at least the most important of
which will return
these are shamiq more as miles morales
hailey steinfeld as gwen stacy and luna
loren the less as miles mother rio along
with probably brian tyree henry as
mild's father jefferson davis
last but not least jake johnson has also
confirmed that he will once again voice
mild mentor peter b parker the latter
will be particularly exciting to see
grow after all his fate was quite open
at the end of the first part
the trio of goalkeeping dos santos camp
powers and justin k thompson will direct
the movie while the screenplay will be
handled by david callahan phil lord and
chris miller
the release day for spider-man into the
spider-verse 2 is scheduled for october
7th 2022
in mid-october just before halloween the
third and final part of david gordon
green's trilogy remake will be released
halloween ants will once again provide
major scares in 2018 the series kicked
off with halloween which is by the way a
direct successor to the 1978 original
completely ignoring all other sequels
and spin-offs in doing so the production
team has absolutely succeeded as hardly
any other horror film remake is as
highly anticipated in 2021 as the second
part of the trilogy halloween kills
which will be released on october 15th
this year
pretty much exactly one year later
halloween ants will follow even though
nothing is known yet about the plot and
the cast it is fairly easy to figure out
from the film's title what the final
part will be about it is considered
certain that laurie and her brother
michael myers will face each other for
one last final showdown on the other
hand director green revealed that
halloween ends could be something that
fans don't have in mind at all in terms
of content in any case we are excited
and look forward to the theatrical
release on october 14th 2022
the next movie the flash is due to be
released in november up to now the dc
project has been known for having worn
out many directors it wasn't until
november 2019 that the wright man was
found namely it director andy muschietti
this is particularly interesting since
musketeer obviously comes from the
horror genre and it is believed that the
upcoming flash will also go in a
somewhat creepier direction
details about the plot are still lacking
but there are some clues that give us an
idea of the plot
the flashpoint event from the dc comics
is the main focus
broadly speaking the flashpoint occurs
when perry allen travels back in time
causing the timeline to plunge into
chaos as a result michael keaton's
batman and many other characters could
make an appearance
what exactly this might look like is
something you will be able to find out
from november 4th 2022
we're slowly approaching the end of 2022
but this doesn't mean there will not be
any more blockbusters watch out because
the release of james cameron's avatar 2
is coming in mid-december the action
takes place about 12 years after the
first part sully is now the clan leader
supported by his wife nathiri of course
emphasis is to be put on the underwater
world of pandora which is in danger due
to exploitative missions of the rda
despite being a sequel according to
cameron the movie stands on its own and
can therefore be watched by newcomers to
the franchise without prior knowledge
fans who already know the predecessor
will be happy to see some familiar faces
the cast includes sam worthington zoe
zaldana matt gerald giovanni ripsey and
many more new additions to the cast are
kate winslet as rona cliff curtis as
tonal warri and eddie falcone as general
art moore the release date for avatar 2
has been set for december 16th 2022
on the same day the last big movie of
the year will finally come out namely
aquaman and the lost kingdom recently
known primarily by boycott calls many
nonetheless have high expectations for
the sequel according to reports aquaman
in the last kingdom will be
significantly more complex than the
first part the plot is still largely
undisclosed though we do already know
some of the cast members of course jason
momoas aquaman amber heard asmera
patrick wilson has ocean master and yaya
tomodi in the second as black manta in
particular the villain black manta is
expected to take a major role in the
sequel fans can also hope for some
horror elements since director is none
other than horror movie icon james 1. as
already stated the end result can be
seen right before christmas starting on
december 16 2022
well so much for our second part of the
most anticipated films of 2022 which
movie are you looking forward to the
most or have we even forgotten an
essential film you're looking forward to
feel free to tell us in the comments and
don't forget to activate the
notification bell after all you never
know when the next trailer for your
favorite movie will be available on our
channel
[Music]